this video was made possible by
betterhelp.com
pacman where you can get affordable
online access to a licensed
therapist through text phone and video
chat
just click the link under this video
there was this simultaneously hilarious
but totally cringe-worthy and very very
embarrassing moment at the united
nations general assembly on
tuesday where donald trump completely
laughably claimed that he's done more
in his first two years as president than
any administration had done in the
history of the united states
and when he did it the leaders of the
entire world laughed at him it's very
clear from the video they're laughing at
him they're not laughing with him
just as a reminder in case you missed
that story from earlier in the week here
is that
extraordinarily cringe-worthy moment
from the united nations earlier this
week
today i stand before the united nations
general assembly
to share the extraordinary progress
we've made
in less than two years my administration
has accomplished more than
almost any administration in the history
of our country
america's so true
didn't expect that reaction but that's
okay
so on wednesday when we covered this
initially we speculated
how would trump defend this and i
suggested that he might say
that they were laughing with him in some
form of solidarity or that he had told a
joke
the fact that he would tell a joke is of
course completely unbelievable the guy
seems to have
no sense of humor whatsoever i don't
know that i've ever seen donald trump
tell or understand a joke told by
someone else
then nikki haley u.s ambassador to the
u.n who was there
tried claiming on fox news that the
laughter
was world leaders expressing how much
they love trump and how much they just
love his honesty
by laughing which is kind of a weird way
to express that right like if i think
someone is so honest and i really
appreciate that i don't know that i
start laughing that's not the reaction i
i would think i'd have in that situation
the thing is this doesn't even need an
explanation
just move on never talk about it that
big of a deal exactly
but net well i i think it is a big deal
i don't think i don't think
the reaction should be a big deal
because you're only calling attention to
it and something that should be negative
the whole world laughing at you i think
is is a problem for the u.s
but now a bunch of the diplomats in the
room confirmed that yeah they were
laughing at trump they were definitely
not laughing with trump there's one
diplomat from latin america
who asked not to be identified because
he wasn't authorized to speak on on
behalf of his country who said quote
sometimes when we see a behavior or
listen to arguments or notions that seem
so far-fetched unreasonable or insane
there is almost natural reaction of
laughing it is not laughing at a good
joke
but a nervous laugh or a bad joke turned
laughable
precisely because the guy who tells the
joke doesn't realize how bad
it is there were a ton of these comments
and they're basically all
spot on and in line from other
diplomats in the room one who said what
would resonate well
at a political rally in america sounded
a little awkward at the u.n general
assembly which was exactly our point of
view which is trump went in and
delivered a line he would give at one of
his rallies
except these are diplomats these are
world leaders this is a different type
of stage it's not low
information voters in where was the most
recent one of pennsylvania or i don't
even know where he was
uh an asian diplomat said quote he
doesn't have
any concept of diplomacy but he did say
that his lack of diplomacy sort of seems
to have worked with regard to north
korea
although i would take issue with that
and then now donald trump is also
claiming that the comment was meant to
get laughter
does anybody believe that does anybody
believe that trump
took credit for improvement in his
country as a way to get people to laugh
like how would anyone under any
circumstances
say that when the president touts
accomplishments
that's what you say to get a room full
of leaders to laugh but he said right
after the awkward pause
i wasn't expecting that reaction but
that's okay
which completely debunks that doesn't it
well maybe that was part of the joke
oh that's that's pretty that's pretty
elaborate this is what i'm talking about
that it's
opinion on a few things it's special
pleading after special pleading and to
go back to what you said a couple
minutes
ago pat i don't get the strategy right
instead of
claiming totally unbelievable things
about the incident
instead of claiming that it was a joke
or it was meant to get a laugh or people
were laughing with you
never mention it again don't call more
attention to it at all
in particular don't call more attention
to it with lies it's it's like playing
chess with someone
who can't understand the impact of their
move on the next move right he says he's
accomplished more than any other
president in history or whatever doesn't
think of the fact that it's a ridiculous
claim and that these are world leaders
not people at a rally and they're going
to laugh
then they laugh and his move is to claim
that
the line was meant to create a room full
of laughing diplomats
and he doesn't seem to realize that it's
kind of a weird way to get laughs
to claim as the leader of a country that
you're doing a good job that that's not
usually the type of joke world leaders
tell
this is like a 24-hour story that the
white house has managed to turn into a
one-week long story
yes and you have to wonder if they did
by accident if they don't mean to
stretch out the length of the story or
if they're trying to distract from other
things going on
namely the robert mueller investigation
or kevin have your hearings yeah
i i agree so let's talk about the
distraction thing a little bit i think
that's interesting
i agree that a lot of what donald trump
and his administration do
is meant to distract from other stuff
that they don't want people paying
attention to
i do think we sometimes give them too
much credit with the distract stuff
i think sometimes they just are terrible
at handling situations and they don't
get how they're making
what could go away an even worse problem
like i get that they often want to
distract i just don't think they're
smart enough to always calculate these
supposed distractions they're
either really bad at playing chess or
they're so good that they're playing the
three or four dimensional chess
that's why i actually have uh i want to
speak specifically to the trump
supporters in the audience today both of
you
uh no okay there's more than that i want
you
to do the adult thing if you're an adult
which is
acknowledge that this is as close as we
can possibly get
to the world literally laughing at the
president of the united states
and they're laughing at trump not at
obama
as trump and his defenders like to claim
was happening everybody's laughing the
world's laughing it's a laughingstock
they're laughing at trump you don't have
to say that you don't long
no longer support the guy you don't have
to say that you you can still agree with
the guy about his dumb trade policy if
you want
but write to me and tell me you know
what the world was laughing at donald
trump you can still support the guy
i encourage you to reach out to me if
you want to tweet me you can do that at
the pacman if you want to tweet the show
we're also on twitter at david pakman
show pull up your big boy pants
and admit that the world is laughing at
the guy that you voted for
tell me you don't care tell me it
doesn't matter tell me you don't care if
the world laughs
but have the honesty to tell me that you
recognize that they're laughing